I want to talk today about the
efficient markets hypothesis.
Uh, and, uh, uh,
let me just first say a last
lecture was about insurance. Uh,
and I was telling you about the theory
of insurance and how it's evolved over
the years, uh, and how it's
produced some real benefits.
Uh,
um,
is that better?
It says Mike Volume.
Did that go up?
Okay. So, um,
I wanted to just tie this in,
uh,
the advantages of insurance that we
have to some big events that occurred.
Uh, and that will, I think, uh,
point out the strengths and
weaknesses of our institutions.
So we had a terrible hurricane a
couple of years ago in Los Angeles.
Uh, Hurricane Katrina, uh, damaged,
uh, the city of, I'm sorry,
did I say Los Angeles?
You have to stop me when I say
things that are, uh, obviously wrong.
Uh,
my mind lapses sometime New Orleans and
Los Angeles doesn't have to worry about
hurricanes as far as I know, unless
there's some major change. Uh,
in New Orleans, uh, there
was a hurricane Katrina, uh,
it, uh, broke the, uh,
levies that were surrounding the city
and cause a flooding of the city. Uh,
and, uh, what, what saved
the people of the city?
Mostly I would say it's actually
the insurance institutions because,
uh,
the city was heavily damaged,
but homes were generally insured.
Uh,
there was some conflicts that
happened when this huge disaster came.
Some people had wind insurance and
some people had flood insurance.
Uh, and, uh, it would be, became,
you came difficult whether this was
a wind or a flood problem, right,
because the wind caused the flood.
So if you had only wind insurance,
are you covered? So there was a lot
of bickering and arguments afterwards,
but I think it worked out well there.
Uh, there, there were surveys of, uh,
customer satisfaction,
uh, after the, uh, event.
And I think generally people were
happy with their insurance companies.
Of course there were some that were not,
who may have found out that they weren't
covered. But, uh, uh, on the whole,
the experience worked well. So, uh,
the other thing I wanted to say
about the last lecture is that, um,
as,
as financial progress moves on,
the distinction between insurance and
other forms of risk management may get
blurred. And one very interesting thing
that's been happening is that, uh,
we are starting to see development of
another institution called the catastrophe
bond, which is a, uh,
another way that people have of protecting
themselves against catastrophes.
And it's not insurance.
So I,
catastrophe bond is a bond that the issuer
doesn't have to pay off if there's a
catastrophe. All right?
So you can have hurricane.
The city of New Orleans could
raise money with catastrophe bonds,
uh, that, uh, uh, they have to
pay back if there's no hurricane,
but, uh, they don't have to pay
back if there is a hurricane,
uh, or it could be some
mixture. They'd pay back.
Part of it if there is a hurricane
that that's like insurance, isn't it?
But it doesn't operate through
an insurance company. Uh,
it operates through the securities market.
So a good example of that
is a couple of years ago,
the government of Mexico issued
catastrophe bonds against earthquakes.
Uh,
Mexico City was hit by a terrible
earthquake about 20 years ago.
Uh,
and it's vulnerable to being hit again.
So what does Mexico do about this?
Mexico could wait until there is a
hurricane and hope that there's some
international relief
effort. Uh, but you know,
that's not a very good way to perceive.
We want to arrange it in advance. So,
uh, what Mexico did, his
issue, cat bonds, uh, that, uh,
have to be repaid in the absence of a
hurricane and have a lower repayment if
there is, I've said it, a hurricane
and not at my desk to form today.
Earthquake in Mexico City does not
have to worry about hurricanes either.
Every area is different and they
have their own, um, their own, uh,
individual, uh,
characteristics. So right now,
the insurance industry
is a bit challenged, uh,
because in terms of some risks,
because the risk seems to be changing
through time, uh, and notably, uh,
it looks like hurricane
risk is increasing. Uh,
and so people who are insured in it
seems to be increasing because of global
warming. Although I don't know if
all scientists are agreed on that.
But if you live in a
coastal area of Florida,
it does appear that your risk
is increasing through time.
So insurance companies want
to raise your rates. Uh,
and this is a huge issue down in Florida.
Well,
the government has kind of taken
over, uh, for the time being, uh,
insurance, uh, in Florida because, uh, we,
we have problems,
uh,
people that are having problems paying
the increased insurance premium. Uh, so,
um, I don't think we've figured
out finally how, uh, uh,
insurance will ultimately
look in a matter of years.
But I think that the important thing is
that it's protecting us against already,
maybe in perfectly,
but it's already protecting us
against some of our worst fears, uh,
like hurricanes and earthquakes.
Uh,
and that I think the system is evolving
and we're getting new developments like
cat, like cat bonds that are
changing the way we're doing things.
And in the future,
I think these will develop more and
make us even better able to handle,
uh, uh, catastrophe risks. Anyway,
that's the last lecture today I wanted
to talk about back to a securities
markets are actually more
general asset markets.
And I want to talk today about
the efficient market's hypothesis,
uh, which is, uh,
a very important intellectual construct,
uh,
that has guided a lot of,
a lot of theory in finance.
Uh,
I want to talk first about
the history of the hypothesis.
I haven't defined it yet for you,
but maybe you already have heard of this.
But a history of the hypothesis
and the arguments for it, uh,
and then the arguments against it.
And I want to talk about
technical analysis and uh,
empirical evidence in the literature
about technical analysis. Uh, and other,
uh, uh, other, uh,
schools of thought that
doubt of market efficiency.
Talk somewhat about behavioral economics.
Um,
and then finally we have a homework
assignment. Actually it's coming up.
I'll start talking about
it now. So, uh, uh,
it'd be an assignment for you to try
to forecast the stock market using
statistical methods. So, uh,
you don't have to look at the screen yet.
It just blinked off.
I'll come back to that. Uh, so the,
uh, what is the efficient
market's hypothesis? Uh,
the term actually is a
fairly recent, uh, origin,
uh, that is, um, a few decades ago.
But the idea it goes back much further.
Uh,
the idea is that in,
in asset markets that have a good,
uh, uh, they have good, uh, uh,
uh, regulations and, uh, uh,
market makers and develop markets that
have a lot of depth and liquidity in
these markets.
The prices that you see are
perfect indicators of true value.
In other words,
efficient markets says that the market
efficiently incorporates all information
and the prices are like
the best information,
uh, about the value of
something. In other words,
the efficient markets hypothesis
tells you trust market,
don't trust people, trust markets. Uh,
so, uh, I've been trying to find
out who said that first. Uh,
and, uh, the earliest, uh,
statement of the efficient
markets hypothesis,
although it doesn't call it the
efficient market's hypothesis.
The earliest statement that I
could find comes from a book, uh,
written in 1889, uh, by George Gibson,
uh, and it's called, um, the
stock exchanges of London,
Paris and New York. Uh,
and, uh, a quote him,
uh,
he said,
when shares become publicly
known in an open market,
the value which they acquire there may
be regarded as the judgment of the best
intelligence concerning them. So, uh,
I kind of interested to see this book.
I found it in the mud library actually
by accident, looking through old,
uh, stock market books.
Uh, and, uh, the, uh,
the book had some
interesting observations.
One observation which took
my interest was that, uh,
he points out that in this
modern electronic age, uh,
information speeds around the
globe at the speed of electricity,
uh, or the speed of light. Uh, when I,
when I first read that, I thought from it,
wait a minute, 1889, that
sounds like 1989 or something.
Are we going to interrupt the,
uh Huh?
Just a moment.
We found the microphone. Why didn't
want him, it was right there.
Sorry about that.
There you go.
No, I'm free from my, from my tether.
Um, in 1889, uh,
they had already invented the Telegraph,
right. That goes back decades earlier. Uh,
and the telephone was,
was starting to appear.
And so it really was true that,
um,
information would speed around the globe.
Uh,
and so information that became publicly
known would be entered into market price
almost immediately. And so the
conclusion that Gibson had was that,
uh, uh, there's no, uh, there's,
there's no hope and trying
to beat the price or, or, or,
or beat the market because the price
already has all of the information in it.
It, let me elaborate on that
theme a little bit. Actually.
It goes back before telegraph.
There was a famous story of a Mr
Writers who had a information service,
uh, before the Telegraph was
invented, uh, and he, uh,
wanted to help his clients,
uh,
get the information first so
that they could trade on it. Uh,
and he had the idea of using a,
what you call a carrier pigeons, uh,
what you do because you get
these birds and you raised them,
you know what I'm talking about,
right?
You raised them in once place and then
they're going to want to go back there.
So then you take them away
in a cage to another city,
and when you need to get a message across,
you tie the message to the
pigeons foot and release it,
and then it will fly back and it
will beat any other method of a,
of a message. Transmission.
Uh, so writer, incidentally,
riders information service is
still in business today. Uh,
and now they use computers that way.
Everyone else does. But the hope,
the whole principle precedes
the invention of computers. Uh,
the idea is that the only way you can
beat the market is to get information that
nobody else has. The way
it works today is that, uh,
uh, the, we can't actually improve
on the speed from 1889 right?
Because they were already going at
virtually the speed of light with their
information. But we can improve
on the, uh, our access to it.
So now many people have
beepers or, uh, you know,
something like this in their pocket
that wakes up and tells them a news is
announced. So what happens when
there is news about a stock?
So let's say it's a drug company that
just makes an announcement that it has a
new drug, let's say good news, uh,
or it has gotten FDA approval
to market some new drug.
What would put that out?
Um, over, uh, over the, uh,
network of information.
And some people would have their,
their things beep on the
men alert them immediately.
There are analysts who try to keep up
with the news about stocks. And so, uh,
these analysts then,
uh,
would jump to action when
they hear that news like that.
That's because they know that markets
move really fast information, uh, to,
uh, important new information. Uh,
and they've got to be there first.
So what happens when the drug company
announces that they have some news
important news?
Well,
the guys who are with their beepers
immediately spring to action and try to
figure out what the news and within
seconds they're trading, because you know,
you've got to be there first.
Uh, otherwise you don't,
you can't benefit from the news.
So what happens that they said they've
announced they've got approval for this
new drug and then they did maybe maybe
do a quick call to their drug company
expert and say, quick, how much should
I change the valuation of the stock?
Uh, and the guy will give a
quick guests, you know, twenties,
this is now 20 seconds
after the announcement,
and then immediately you place a big
trade for a million shares or Flusser
mounted. And then the guy calls
back 30 seconds later and says,
oh, no, you know, I wasn't
exactly right on it.
I've had 30 more seconds to think
about this, so let me change it again.
Uh, so over the next few
minutes, the price, a lot of
people are trading like that.
So the price is jumping around rapidly.
Uh,
then after maybe five minutes,
these people that have had time to
assimilate it and think about it and check
their thinking and the
price starts to settle down.
Maybe I'm exaggerating
how fast it sells them.
Maybe an hour later you have a committee
meeting and the experts are arguing
about, uh, about what this
really means and trying to, uh,
assimilate other information and
coordinate with it. But after two hours,
it started to really settle down.
So suppose you then the next day read in
the Wall Street Journal about this new
announcement.
Do you think you have any
chance of beating the market
by trading on it? I mean,
you're like 24 hours late, but I hear
people tell me, I hear, you know,
I read in Business Week that
there's a new announcement.
So I'm thinking of buying and I say,
well,
business week that that information
is probably a week old. Uh,
even other people we'll talk about trading
on information that's years old. Uh,
and so you kind of think that maybe
these people are, are naive. You know,
first of all, you're not a drug company
expert or whatever it is that's needed.
Uh, secondly, you, you
don't know the math.
You don't know how to calculate present
value is probably, and then, uh,
and then thirdly, you're a
month late. Uh, and so, uh,
you get the impression that a lot of
people shouldn't be trying to beat the
market. Uh, and that, uh, you
might say to a first approximation,
the market has it all right.
And so don't even try.
Uh,
so the efficient markets hypothesis is a,
a hypothesis that one should
respect financial markets. Uh,
very much so. Your Textbook, uh, by, uh,
for Bozi at Al mentioned,
I looked it up in the index to see
what they say about efficient markets
hypothesis. They define it. Uh,
according the textbook for Bozi,
uh,
publicly available relevant information
about the issuers will lead to correct
pricing of freely traded securities
in properly functioning markets.
That's their definition of the
efficient markets hypothesis.
Uh, they didn't say it was right.
They just said that's the hypothesis.
What for Bozi et Al Said is that the,
uh,
the hypothesis has informed
a lot of regulation.
The Securities and Exchange Commission
and other agencies that regulate
financial markets,
uh,
have shown some faith in the efficient
markets hypothesis and therefore they
feel that their, um, their,
maybe their primary mission is to regulate
the flow of information to make sure
that it's an even playing field so that
everyone has access to information at
the same time. Uh, so for example,
the Securities and Exchange Commission
requires that when a corporation
publishes information that's
relevant to the value of their stock,
they have to put it out
to everyone at once. Uh,
well there's rules about what that means,
but typically they'll have a webcast or
something like that and it's announced
in advance. So everyone who is really
interested can, can listen in. Uh,
but I don't find a
whole lot of enthusiasm.
And if avast he'd work for the
efficient markets hypothesis.
And maybe that's because it's not
exactly right, which is my view.
It's a half truth. And I'll come back
to that. I wanted to quote another,
uh, bestselling textbook,
not your own. Uh,
but there's another textbook Breely
and admires, uh, which is a textbook,
a of corporate finance.
Uh,
and they are much more enthusiastic
about efficient markets hypothesis.
At the end of their textbook, they
have a concluding chapter, uh,
and the concluding chapter is built
around what they call the seven most
important ideas in finance.
And one of those seven ideas to
them is efficient markets. Uh,
and, uh, they don't call it a hypothesis.
He just say efficient markets,
which they define as the,
the theory that I'm quoting them.
Security prices accurately
reflect available information
and respond rapidly to
new information.
As soon as it becomes available,
then they have a little qualifier. I
think there's interesting, they say,
don't misunderstand the
efficient market idea.
It doesn't say that there
are no taxes or costs.
It doesn't say that there aren't some
clever people and some stupid ones.
It merely implies that competition
in capital markets is very tough.
There are no money machines and security
prices reflect the true underlying
value of assets. Uh, well that's, uh,
that's a pretty enthusiastic
endorsement of efficient markets. Uh,
I said I have some doubts
about it. I guess I, I, uh, uh,
I don't, I guess what I don't like,
is there a concluding statement?
Security prices reflect the
true underlying value of assets.
I don't think that's a really true,
uh,
but I guess I agree it's tough to make
money reliably and quickly in financial
markets. And so if that's what efficient
markets means, uh, there, right.
Um, so, um, but you know,
efficient markets is not so
easy to define. Uh, there,
uh, we go back to, um, in, uh,
the terminal,
he goes back to 1967 and it was professor
Harry Roberts at University of Chicago
who defined three different
efficient market's hypothesis. Uh,
there is the
weak form,
the semi strong form,
and then the strong form,
uh,
the weak form.
These differ only in terms of the amount
of information that is assumed to be
efficiently incorporated into prices.
The weak form says that
Info of past prices
is already in the incorporated
into price. So, uh,
uh, but, but only past prices.
What it means only is that you can't
predict stock prices, but noting that,
say if it goes up today, it'll probably
go up tomorrow or if it goes up today,
it'll probably go down tomorrow.
That would be relying only on past prices.
And so Harry Robert felt most confident
that this a form of the hypothesis was
was uh, it was good. So he
call it a week. For him,
it's the least criticized of
a form of efficient markets.
Semi strong form says that market
prices incorporate all public info
information.
Anything that's known to the public is
already incorporated into the price.
So don't bother to trade on it.
The strong form says all information,
whether public or not,
is it incorporated into price?
This is a really strong,
it's the least likely to be true because
every time you increase the information
set,
what strong form says is that
no information is private.
Really, it all gets out into
price. Uh, companies keep secrets.
And so that's not public information.
The Securities and Exchange Commission
insists that companies keep secrets
because they have to disseminate
information in an orderly way.
And so there has to be a secret until a
certain hour in which it's announced to
everybody.
But the strong form efficient markets
hypothesis is cynical about that and said,
you know, nobody keeps
secrets. It all leaks out. Uh,
I think that when we refer to
the efficient markets hypothesis,
it's the semi strong form that we're
usually referring to because the strong
farm is a bit, uh, a bit strong. And, um,
okay, so, um,
the definitions of efficient markets
that I gave you a are intuitive but not
very precise because then you have to
ask, well, what does it mean to say that,
uh, price incorporate all information? Uh,
what does it mean to incorporate
information? Uh, so, uh,
there's not one answer to that question.
Uh,
and so I'm going to give
the simplest answer. Uh,
what does efficient markets
mean? Uh, and, uh, I might,
I'll have to raise,
this is the simplest version,
but it's often the one that's
often the one that is referred to most.
And that is that price
is the expected value,
the expected present value of
future dividends paid on the stock.
Okay. Uh, and so, uh,
the,
uh,
the efficient markets hypothesis,
it says the true value of a stock
comes from the dividends that it pays.
That's a cash flow that is valued by the
market and the market values it as the
present value of the optimally
forecasted future dividends.
Okay. So, uh,
and the theory that's most
often referred to is the simple,
uh, I, I've already talked in the second
lecture about present value of 400 rows.
We had a growing perpetuity models.
Uh,
remember that I said
that the present value,
the present discounted value of a
growing perpetuity that pays an amount d,
uh,
if it pays,
if the pant is d times e to the GT,
mmm.
Are these subzero either
the GT is the dividend,
so it's growing at rate lowercase g there.
Then the formula we had for the
present value was d over r minus G.
I remember that.
Um,
and uh,
this assumes of course that the growth
rate of dividends has to be less than the
discount rate are.
So the simplest version of the efficient
markets hypothesis says price is equal
to the dividend all over the,
in the discount rate minus the
growth rate of dividends where, Gee,
the growth rate of dividends is a,
is an optimally forecasted growth rate
of dividends. And so that gives us,
uh, evaluate a model
for the, uh, uh, price.
Uh,
another way of writing more generally
as if I don't assume the constant growth
rate of dividends is to write
just a present value formula.
It's another, uh, less strong form of, uh,
writing down the efficient markets
hypothesis because it doesn't say how
dividends are thought to grow,
but you can write the price is equal
to the summation of the expectation at
time.
T of dividends at time.
T plus k all over one plus r to the
Keith Power k equals one to infinity.
This is another incarnate that that's
just the present value formula.
I have the price,
I'm sorry.
They should be the expectation at yeah,
Tang t
the price at time.
T is the expectation of
the dividend at time.
People pay discounted by,
uh, a discount factor are,
uh,
and that's just the present value formula
where I've substituted an expectation,
uh, for the future dividend. So, um,
uh, that's the efficient market
theory in this incarnation.
There's other ways to envision the
efficient markets, what it means,
but let's consider this simple story.
What this means then is that, uh, the, uh,
price
is a forecast of future dividends
to be paid on the stock.
This, this would be a of the present value
of future dividends to be paid on the
stock. And this means
then that, uh, price, uh,
relative to dividends, uh, is, uh,
related to expected future
growth rates of dividends.
If you expect dividends to grow a lot,
if g is high,
then price will be high
relative to dividends because
this is subtracted off the
denominator. It makes the denominator is
smaller and it makes the price higher.
Uh, on the other hand, if you expect
dividends to do poorly in the future,
then price will be low
relative to dividends.
That's what the efficient markets
hypothesis would say. Uh, and so,
uh, um, I would give
you an example of that.
Um, I talked last year about a
company that I read in Business Week,
uh, read about in Business Week. Um, so
this is a year old story in Business Week.
Uh, there was a company
called first fed financial,
which was a company that issues mortgages.
And already this was in January of 2000
and said actually the business week
story.
It was in December of 2006,
but I was still reacting to it
in a year ago in January of 2007.
Uh, and so, uh, uh, the, uh,
businessweek story,
this is first fed financial,
uh, was referring to the fact that, uh,
the price dividend ratio, actually
they talked about price earnings ratio,
but the, the, the price
earnings ratio for this company,
uh,
was very low.
It was only 8.5 in, um, in, uh,
in December,
2006.
That's 8.5 and right that very clearly,
typically price earnings ratios
of companies are very high,
much higher than that,
typically like 15. So, uh,
the price of first fed financial
relative to its earnings was very low.
And so some people might be inclined
to think, well, that looks cheap.
I can buy by buying first fed financial,
I can buy the stock at a low
price relative to its earnings.
But if you believe in efficient markets,
you wouldn't think that this is
any reason to buy the company.
Because efficient markets would say that
if the price is low relative to either
dividends or earning,
it must mean that people think that
bad things are going to come to the
dividends are earnings.
In other words,
the first fed financial has a
low expected growth rate of,
of dividends in the future.
Uh,
and so I was interested in this particular
story because Business Week wrote an
article about them,
uh,
and noted the low price
earnings ratio and said,
uh, what does this mean? Uh, uh, and what,
what businessweek presented a year ago
was an argument why g was likely to be
low.
Yes.
Right?
Uh, yes. If they don't pay dividends,
you can't use this formula.
And I'm not sure what the
dividends were first fed financial.
I only know the price earnings ratio, uh,
at that time. But you're, you're right,
you cannot use this formula if they're
not paying a dividend today because,
uh, the, uh, um,
this formula I erased it,
but it was up here assumes that dividends
are following a growth path and your,
and if they're not paying dividends
then that we were very clearly,
that's not inappropriate assumption.
Yeah.
Right. So for Berkeley,
incidentally, if you know,
Berkshire Hathaway is the company that
Warren Buffet a owns and it's a very
famous company cause
it's done extremely well.
And Warren Buffet is regarded as by
many people as a financial genius. Um,
but if Berkshire Hathaway
is not paying a dividend,
we have to revert to this formula.
So the efficient market theory would say,
well, they're going to pay a dividend
eventually. And so the price reflects, uh,
these future terms.
If you spell this out,
this is the expected dividend next year,
plus the dividend in two years,
just divided by one plus r squared plus
the expected dividend and three years
divided by one plus r cubed, et cetera.
So this theory would say that, uh,
the dividend that Berkshire Hathaway
has value only because they investors
expect them to pay dividends
in the future. Um, and that,
that sounds right because if Berkshire
Hathaway is never going to pay dividends,
why would you hold it?
You might say,
I'll hold it because I could sell to
someone else at a higher price. Uh,
but then you said, well, why
would anyone else buy it? Look,
if they're never going to pay a dividend,
what good is it?
It's just a piece of paper.
Write it.
Unless I can sell to a greater fool.
But anyone who buys it,
it's either would be buying either on
the assumption that there is some greater
fool coming or they would be the fool,
a fool of themselves.
So this theory says that the value,
if Warren Buffet,
cause he can't even say this,
but let's somehow say the company could
say, we will never pay a dividend.
This company is going to give
it away to charity. Someday.
You won't get a penny as a
stockholder. Well, if that happened,
the price should be zero. It would convert
into a nonprofit like Yale University.
So what's the price of a share in Yale
University? I mean it's undefined.
I guess it's zero, right? Because
Yale is not paying, I'll write,
I'll write a piece of paper for you and
said, this is a share on my, my authority.
This is a share in Yale University.
Um,
and it might just as well be that
because it also says in my fine print,
you will never get a dividend on
this. So what's the point? Right? Uh,
so, uh, incidentally Microsoft for
many years never paid a dividend.
It's often common for young
companies not to pay dividends,
but they did start paying
a dividend. And, uh,
the whole theory of efficient
markets theory says that that's what,
that's what people are looking for.
That's why the,
the value of a company is related
to its activities. Otherwise,
even if the company never paid a dividend,
that what would you care
what the company is doing?
You only care about it because someday
they're going to give you money.
A lot of investors forget that.
That's a very naive thing, attitude.
They think that somehow it's docs
generate capital gains, prices go up.
But you have to realize in efficient
markets, theory is saying this,
that prices only go up because there's
new information about future dividends.
Um, okay, so, um, the first financial,
anyway,
this is an efficient market story.
First financial had a low PE and so
people were wondering, is this a bargain?
This is a cheap stock. Pe
means price earnings ratio. Uh,
and uh,
the business week article pointed out
that 40% of first federal had been sold
shorts.
40% of their stock had been sold short.
This is a very high level of short
shortages. Do you know what that means?
That means a lot of investors said,
uh,
I don't like first fed financial. I don't
want to invest in it worse than that,
I want to go and short them.
So that means you borrow shares and sell
them and hope that the price goes down.
When you have 40% of
the shares sold short.
That means that there's a lot of
people who didn't believe in first fed
financial. So business weekend,
it's article pointed out that uh,
this first fed financial, it
was a, a small mortgage lender.
This is the before the mortgage crisis
that we're in and started in Santa Monica,
California. Uh, and that
it was particularly, uh,
innovative in a chance in its lending,
notably 80% according to
the business week article,
80% of the mortgages it's
issued were no doc mortgages.
And you know,
the no doc mortgage,
it's something that appeared
recently in the housing frenzy.
A No doc mortgage is a mortgage
where you walk in and say,
I want to borrow money to buy this
house. And the company says, fine,
we'll give you a mortgage.
We won't even ask you to send a,
have your employer sends a letter
saying that you have a job.
We won't even ask you to prove
that you own anything or have,
we'll just give you the mortgage.
Uh, that's considered by many people,
risky behavior, but it was done
during the housing boom. Also,
they,
they issued a unusually high proportion
of what are called option arms.
These are mortgages that
are adjustable rate,
but also the person doesn't have to pay
the full payment every time you have the
option of paying. And if you don't want
to pay, you can delay it for a while.
And these are also controversial because
it thought they would attract borrowers
who are unreliable,
uh,
borrowers who thought that they could
afford the house because they didn't have
to pay now,
but of course it's all going to come
later and then they might default.
So business,
we thought that the low price earnings
ratio was because the market expected
earnings to go down, uh, and
dividends to go down. So I,
a year later,
that is,
this morning I wanted to see what
first fed financial is doing.
Uh, and actually it's still in
business. Everything's alright.
It has positive earnings,
uh, but it's price.
The price was $70,
uh,
in beginning of 2007,
and now it's down to about $40.
A 2008.
So, uh, this is a testimony
to efficient markets. Uh,
the market was expecting
the price earnings ratio.
They gave it a low PE because
they were worried about,
they had information that there was
something going badly in this company.
And indeed they were
right. Uh, it, you know,
it's not as bad as you might've
thought with the business week story,
but it is bad. So, uh,
uh, I guess the lesson,
are you following what I'm talking?
So what happened was they did
get into trouble. Uh, the, uh,
uh,
the low PE was indeed a forecaster of,
of, uh, of bad performance later.
Uh, but, um, uh,
so,
um,
now I guess this isn't exactly efficient,
efficient markets wouldn't,
in this case,
the,
the people who sold first fed financial
short made a lot of money, uh,
when the price went down so much.
That's not really consistent
with efficient markets
because it makes it sound
like I, as a matter of fact, I could have,
I could have reading the business
week article at the beginning of 2007.
I could have called my broker and
I could have told my broker, uh,
short please,
I want to short first fed financial
and I could have done that.
And I looked like I've made a lot of
money right by shorting it because the
price went down a lot. Efficient
markets theory, uh, would,
would have to say, uh, that that was an
anomaly, that that was just good luck.
Those people who shorted
first fed financial did make
a lot of money, but hey,
they were just lucky this time.
Another word,
efficient markets theory would say that
the price was already down as far as,
you know,
basically as far as it would go in
2007 and that earnings would fall,
uh, and dividends would fall later and
that would explain why the price was low,
but it wouldn't allow you to predict
the price. So this and this anomaly,
uh, uh, uh, the, the,
the fact that it worked out so well is
really not test two short investors,
uh, is really not testimony
too efficient and markets
efficient market. You know, in some
sense I think I, I'm sympathetic,
efficient mark.
We have to be sympathetic to some extent.
If I were to try and I actually did not
short first fed financial when I read
this last year and it was because
I guess I had my doubt, you know,
I had my feeling you read a business
week article, you know, and it's a,
it's everyone in the world knows it now
that a lot of people doubt first fed
financial. So if I come in late as a short
seller, am I going to do well? You know,
I start to doubt myself because there's
so many people looking at it and so many
people who are more knowledgeable
about first fed financial, I am so,
you know,
maybe I won't try shorting it and that
that's what efficient markets is all
about. Um, so, uh,
the efficient market theory became
very popular in finance, uh,
in about, um, about, uh,
w w when Iran in 1970 and it became a,
uh,
uh, a prominent theory and finance, uh,
it has a particular incarnation
that I wanted to emphasize, uh,
called random walk. Uh, and
so the random walk theory,
uh, which follows loosely from
this formula that I have to
qualify it.
But let me talk about random
walking as a theory in itself.
The random walk theory
says that under efficient markets,
stock prices and other a speculative
asset prices are random walks.
And that term goes back to Carl Pearson,
uh,
in an article in nature in 1905.
So this idea is about, uh,
about a hundred years old. Uh,
and what, uh, Pearson wrote about was
where the example he gave was a drunk.
Imagine the person who is so drunk that
every step that person takes is random
and independent of the preceding
step. Okay. And so suppose we,
uh, this is 1905 story.
Suppose we had, uh,
a lamppost and we had a drunk
standing at the lamp post.
I've had drawn a picture that's
a lamppost and that's a drunk,
this person is so intoxicated that
steps are completely around them.
And your object is to predict where
will this person be in one minute,
in 10 minutes and 20 minutes. Okay,
well Pearson wrote about this.
It said that the optimal prediction is to
assume that the person in 10 minutes,
the best forecast is the person
will be here in 10 and 20 minutes.
What's the best forecast person who will
be here? Of course they probably want,
because they're randomly
staggering around.
But the point is that if it's a
true random rock, there's no bias.
It's equally likely to
go this way or this way.
The most likely place for the person
is right where that person is now.
And so,
uh,
Pearson and other people following him
thought that speculative prices are like
that. That that sounds like the
markets are crazy. They're drunk,
but they're not drunk. It's, it's,
it's because they respect
all need to new information.
And so new information is by
its essence and forecastable.
And so it has to look like the
market is driven by a drunk,
when in fact it's very precise and
responding optimally to new information.
So that's one of the paradoxes
that confuses people. Uh,
so our statisticians develop
the theory of a random one.
And let me define it for you.
A random walk occurs when you have,
uh,
a very,
variable x at time t
is equal to x at time.
T minus one plus epsilon,
sub t where epsilon to be is noise.
Unforecasted forecastable noise.
Okay, so this is a random walk.
X would be here.
How far the person is from the
lamppost. Here's zero. Let's say,
okay,
x is the distance from the lamppost.
So at every time interval we have x of t,
which is how far the drunk has
deviated from the lamp post.
This is the random step. This is where
the drunk was last period and we're,
this is where the drunk is this period.
Okay?
So that's a random walk. Uh, and the, uh,
in the heyday of efficient markets theory,
people said that efficient markets
is working very well. In other words,
the random walk hypothesis,
uh,
describes stock prices very well.
So let me go to my spreadsheet,
which I have up here. Uh,
and uh,
uh,
I'll put this spreadsheet
up on the web for you. Uh,
what I have here is shown,
uh, there's two lines shown.
One is a blue line, uh, which is, um,
the,
uh,
the Blue Line is the actual standard
and poor composite stock price index.
Uh, going back to 1871,
this is a series that I,
well actually it got this theories
from standard and Poor's. Uh,
I emphasize it a lot in my
book. It's a hundred. Uh,
it's a a 130 year long stock price series
money monthly for the United States.
It's now called the s and p 500.
Um,
because starting in 1957
standard and poor, well,
they kind of reorganized the index
and they kept it at 500 stocks.
So this is the second most famous
stock price index after the Dow Jones
industrial average.
Uh,
but I think it's better than the Dow
Jones industrial average because the dow
has only 30 stocks.
And this has 500,
it's representative of most of the
market. So that's history. That blue,
that Blue Line there is history.
Okay.
Now what I did on excel is I,
um,
I generated a random mark because there's
a random number generator on excel.
I used the random number and
plugged it into this formula.
A X of t equals x of t
minus one plus Epsilon T.
And that pink line is a true random lark.
It was generated by a random
number generator. Okay.
And the point here is don't
they look kind of similar.
Okay. Uh, when you look at, uh,
when people look at stock pricing,
they get an a, it's an illusion.
This is a psychological illusion.
They get the sense that,
uh,
there are bull markets when the market
is going up and there are bear markets
when the market is going down and it must
be some force pushing it up for awhile.
Um, but, uh, so you can see, for
example, I'm looking at the Blue Line,
there was a bull market in the
1920s, a famous boat market, right?
The roaring twenties.
Uh,
and so you would say that
can't just be a random walk.
It was just going up all the time.
And then this is the 1929 peak.
And look at there is the crash
from 1929 to 1932 big crash.
That can't be a random walk,
right? That's what people think.
They have this intuitive idea.
But if you look,
this random walk seems to do the
same thing. The pink line, uh, has,
uh, look, there was a nice bull market
there and there's another crash. Look at,
look at this whole period here. This was
really strong and then it leveled out.
We had bad bet. They kind
of look similar, don't they?
This is pure chance because that random
mark that I generated was pure random
walk.
But that there's the bull,
the actual bull market of the 1950s
and sixties. And my random walk,
it comes out pretty close to that.
So the random walk theory says that people
are operating under the illusion that
there really is no trends or uh,
there's no way to predict the market.
It is just completely and
forecastable. Now, incidentally,
a nice thing about excel is I can generate
a new random walk for you on the spot
by pressing f nine if you
know that key on excel.
So I will press f nine and
history is going to stay the same.
The Blue Line is going to stay the same,
but the pink line is going
to change and I'm going to,
I can generate whole hundred year history
pseudo histories with the press of a
button. So let's see if this
works. Okay. We just got,
what does that thing?
Okay.
I put an upward trend to
the random walk there, uh,
because I think there's an
uptrend to the stock market.
So it's a little different than this.
I just added a time trend.
Otherwise it's exactly that random
walk formula that I use. Okay.
That looks pretty much like history too.
Except we would be in a bear market for,
for quite a while, right? We have
quite a bear market in the pink line,
but I can correct that by
pressing f nine again. Well,
well, this is bad luck. Uh,
the stock market crashed and
it went off the chart. Uh,
here, uh, that's bad luck,
but I can try again. Oh, look,
looking at that one.
Isn't that a beauty that almost,
that almost a well, it really,
it really looked like the market.
Yeah.
Um,
so I can just go, it's just amazing
how fast this thing generates.
Look at that.
Well, I should stop. Tell me when
one looks really interesting.
Okay.
That's an interesting one.
That's, that's if that,
if that was the history
that we randomly had,
Jeremy Siegel would write not
just stocks for the long run,
he would be jubilant
their returns on stock.
He would say for a hundred years.
This is like,
this is 130 years for 130 years.
Stocks have wonderfully outperformed
the market outperformed us.
Other things like that, that, that
is looking pretty good, isn't it?
And I just pressed the button and
get like, getting many bad ways.
That's how I have an uptrend in it.
Uh,
but they all look similar right now.
The other thing I wanted to talk about
was a, uh, another thing called a ar one,
which is a different
story. Uh, and the Ar one,
uh,
this is the random walk here.
The other idea is, let me
do it intuitively. First,
I'm going to tie in elastic cord
around the ankle of the drunk.
Okay. And target to the
lamp Paul. And okay,
you see my elastic cord?
It's very lucid beginning so the
drunk can move freely. But if, if it,
if it starts to get stretched and when
the drug makes it all the way over here,
then it's really hard for, it's
pulling the drunk back. Okay.
So that means it biases the
drunk back towards the uh,
starting point.
Uh,
and that's called a ar one or first
order
auto regressive,
a
model.
And so that means that there is something,
the random walk has no center.
It just has a starting point.
It doesn't tend to go back anywhere.
But here we have a center,
uh, what do I call that?
I'll call it the x bar is this point here,
not necessarily a zero.
And it says that x sub t minus x bar
is equal to x bar plus row times x sub
t minus one minus x Bar Plus Epsilon T.
Okay.
And row a row lies between
minus one and plus one. Usually it's
positive. All right, you see that?
So row is the smaller row is
the tighter the elastic cord is.
So, um, it, it,
it gets pulled back by one minus row
the way back to the x bar in every time
period. But then there's new noise that
Alexander it. If there were no new noise,
then the drunk would we just
be gradually pull back. But uh,
but there's new Norris and so the uh,
the drunk is not so,
uh, uh, the drunk is not so predictable.
Okay? So that's another
model of the stock market,
but it's not an efficient markets model.
Uh,
the random walk is
efficient markets model.
It says you can't profit
by trading because you just
cannot predict a change in
price.
But with the first order auto regressive,
you can predict the change of
price at least a little bit.
Well when it's, when, when what
goes up comes down. If the,
if the drunk is over here,
it tends to get pulled back here.
If the drunk is over here,
he tends to get pulled back up.
And so that's the random walk man. So
I programmed into this program, uh,
and ar one,
so I go down here and click on it.
That looks very different doesn't it?
Maybe I didn't get the parameters exactly
right, but let me just hit f nine.
I'll get to it looks better. Well,
it looks a little different, right?
You see a difference in this?
That's because I chose,
I chose row equals 0.95
for that diagram. So it's going
to getting tug back to the trend.
Um, but at sometimes it's hard
to tell. I mean, I thought,
can you tell the difference between
a random walk and an ar one?
It seems to be coming back faster.
So, uh, that, that looks different.
Well, with Roy 4.95, I guess it, it
does look noticeably different, right?
Because,
uh,
it's coming back pretty fast.
I have 130 years observations and it's
coming back 5% of the way every year.
So in five years it's 25% of the way back.
I've got the cord too tight.
So it's not fooling you,
right?
You can see a difference between this ran
this ar one and the true stock market,
the stock. So this is revealing some
truth to the efficient markets hypothesis.
But what if I made real equal 0.99?
Then I think I should have
done that instead of 0.95.
And then it gets harder for
you to see the difference.
And if I make row equals one in the US,
what happens if I plug roe
equals one into this expression?
It comes back to the random walk,
right?
Cause the x bar is drop out because
you've got one times x bar and you've got
one minus x bar over here.
So they drop out of the equation
and you'd come back up here.
So a random walk is just a one
with a coefficient of a row of one.
Uh,
now the point is then that we can
easily see that the stock market is not
strongly mean reverting
or trend reverting,
but it's somewhat maybe
somewhat trend to be run.
It's very hard to tell whether
it's row is one or 0.99.
And so that's, that's the point
of, of my little analysis here, uh,
of random walk versus ar one.
So I'm okay now, uh, the, the homework,
the problem set, uh, that you
will have a next time. Now,
you still haven't turned
in your second problem set,
but I want to work ahead now to the,
to the third one.
But I want you to do is to try
forecasting the stock market.
Uh, and so let me show you what I did
here and I want you to do something.
You could use this spreadsheet,
but I'm also encouraging
you to find your own data.
So here is my spreadsheet,
um, which uh, uh,
has stock prices back to 1871.
Can you see all this?
Uh, I have this on my website all the
time. I've had it on my website. Um,
how long? It must be 20
years. I've, I've been just,
I give it away because I,
I'm,
I'm the person who updates s and p data,
uh,
for,
1871 to the present and s and p I now
have a relationship with SNP cause there
are publishing our indices,
but they still don't provide updates
of this hundred year long series.
So here it is, uh, all
the way back to 1871.
So what do I have here?
Uh,
I have in column one is the essence,
the standard and poor composite dark
price index today called the s and p 500.
Okay.
This is the dividend on the s and p 500
even paying a dividend consistently.
It's never missed a year.
Maybe some companies have missed a year
like Berkshire Hathaway or Microsoft,
but the, but the whole aggregate
has never missed a year.
This is the earnings reported on the
companies. All right? It's all per share.
All right, so this is a
first year earnings. Uh,
and I have here the consumer
price index in this column. Okay.
And then, uh, and I've got long
term interest rate and I can,
I can convert it to a real price,
uh,
by dividing by the consumer price index.
Uh,
and this is the change in the
real price. Okay. I don't, it's,
it's between this year and
the next year. And so, uh,
what I wanted to do is this
is your homework assignment
and maybe I'll come back
to this or maybe your tas
will come back to it as well.
I want you to try to forecast
the stock market. Okay? Uh,
and so that means, but remember
what you're trying to forecast.
You're trying to forecast epsilon,
you're not trying to forecast x.
We already know x is easy to forecast.
It's close to what it was last period.
That's the hard thing is to predict
where the next change will be.
So I had to generate a column
of data here, uh, which is the,
um, uh, which is the change in the price.
So you see up here it says,
uh,
J 10 minus day nine,
is the change in the price. That's what
you want to try to forecast. All right.
And so, um, uh,
I created this column going all the way
back to 1871 showing for each year how
much the,
uh,
s and p composite index
in real terms change.
I did it in logs. I took the
change in the log, the real price.
So that's essentially the
percentage change that is
going to be hard to forecast.
Obviously it's going to be hard to
forecast because there's some truth to the
efficient markets hypothesis.
If that were easy to forecast,
you could have been rich. However, this
fear, somebody could have been written,
it can't be that easy. Uh, nonetheless,
the problems that for you is to try
to do that, to try to forecast it.
So you have to do is go to regression
analysis and you don't have to use excel,
but that's just what I'm suggesting
here because that's the easiest thing.
So to run a regression,
uh, you go up to tools,
uh, and uh, let me see data, oops,
data analysis,
you can't even find it down here.
Uh,
and then you got to regression.
Uh, I guess I have to say. Okay. And
then it asks you to fit fill in Europe,
uh,
x range and your y range.
So the x variable is the, remember
the regression model, uh, is,
um,
it's m
y equals Alpha plus Beta x plus
some error term epsilon or you,
I know, I call it you. So we
don't get mixed up. All right?
So it's asking you to say
where are your y variable is a,
and I've got my wive
variable is in column K,
right? Because that's what I've generated.
That the change, uh, in, uh, the k,
oh wait, I've lost it. I can't,
it's not column k. It's a,
and if I can do it,
it's a,
I'm trying to find it here.
It's calm.
I isn't it,
the move this,
okay.
That's the change in price. Uh, and then
the x variable, I can pick some variable.
The forecast, what I did is I
just took column a, which is time.
It's just the year. Uh, and
I ran the regression, uh,
since 1950 and I got the results here.
Uh, right here. Whoops.
Let's get rid of it.
I'm just going to show you the
results from what regression I man.
That's how excel prints out
regression results. Uh, and uh,
the Alpha, the Alpha, which
is the intercept is, um,
it's shown here.
So the intercept was 0.05.
The Beta, uh, is, uh,
the coefficient of the variable is minus
two times 10 to the minus fifth power.
Uh, you can see it. Now I've struck out,
it doesn't like time as a forecast.
It's a very small coefficient.
Uh,
the key statistic is a measure
of statistical significance
and the t statistic
should probably be over to first just to
go significant and insignificant piece
statistics for both Alpha
and for Bayer. So, um,
the r squared is a measure of what
fraction of the dependent variable y is
variance I have predicted.
And so it comes out with
a fraction of 0.00014,
seven. All right, this is not a success.
This is not a get rich
quick story because, uh,
I'm explaining a one 10000th of
the variance of the stock market.
So, uh, I've, I struck out,
I wasn't really trying that hard. I
just regressed the returns on time. Um,
so the problems that for you
is to, uh, think about, uh,
seeing if you can forecast the market.
Uh, you don't have to use my data set.
You can use others. Uh, and uh,
you can go online and find them.
For example, finance dot.
yahoo.com has a lot of indexes, uh,
but you can find them on other sites.
Um,
so if you find some other data and
you can try to see if you can beat me,
I not setting up a very high
standard for success. Uh,
if it were this bad efficient markets,
well,
this looks good for efficient
markets theory. So, um, uh,
uh, so, but, uh,
what I thought you might
do for the problems that is
to try to think creatively
about how to forecast the market.
And let me say this, uh, I'm not, uh,
I'm going to have to go and continue
with my doubts about efficient markets in
another lecture. But, uh, I,
I think that the story has a
good element of truth to it.
It has to be hard to beat the market,
but it's oversold as well,
especially in academic circles.
I think us professors who are poor are,
you know,
it's kind of a wishful thinking by us.
We're not making much money
and you can't. Anyway. Uh,
and so,
uh,
we kind of over at tend to overstate
efficient markets hypothesis and the other
hand relative to your expectations
as naive young people, uh,
it may be a good thing to do to
overstate efficient market's hypothesis.
There seems to be a life cycle effect
where young people think I can surely
predict the market. Uh, and then
they get beaten down. Um, uh,
Brad, Barbara and Terry Odn
who are professors at UC,
at different campuses of California,
teamed up with, uh, economists from,
uh, Taiwan, uh, and looked at data of,
they got really good data from
Taiwan about day traders, uh,
and their actual returns that they traders
are people who trade every day in the
markets. Uh, and they found that there
was a really predictable pattern.
The young people, they started
out as a day trader, uh,
and they quickly lose it and then they
lose badly cause they're trading too much
and they really can't predict the market.
There's like 1% of them though,
who seem like they can
actually beat the market.
This looks like really good
for efficient markets. Uh,
but they found that there are some
Taiwanese people who know how to beat the
market.
1% survives and stays in.
So is that contrary to efficient markets?
Well,
it does seem contrary because they found
a small number of people did find some
forecasting rule and succeeded.
On the other hand, none of, uh,
hardly any of them got really rich.
And so it's very rare.
Warren buffet is an extremely
rare outcome. And so it's,
I guess when I talk about
efficient markets, I want to, uh,
help prevent you from suffering under
any delusions about your forecasting
ability.
But I don't mean that Warren Buffet can't
do it or that you can't do it if you
develop yourself into a Warren buffet.
So the next,
the problem set number three asks you
to think creatively about how you would
forecast the market and to take a
stab at it by running a regression.
And I expect you all to fail,
or almost all of you to fail your grade
will not depend on your success in
forecast.
It may even depend inversely,
because if you show a big
success in forecasting,
you're a teaching assistant will look at
it very carefully and try to find some
mistake you made because if you do
succeed, uh, it's probably a mistake.
Uh, on the other hand, I don't want to
tell you that you can't because as I said,
we're going to come back to this,
but I have doubts about efficient markets
and I think that you just might be
able to do it if you're smart about it.